will black adam be worth the wait for
the millions and millions of the rox
fans or will it be rock bottom here's
the lowdown
with a release date fast approaching
marketing has been building anticipation
for dwayne the rock johnson's latest box
office smash black adam as expected the
first official trailer debuted in time
to pump up audiences during the latest
summer blockbuster hits
a second trailer debuted for audiences
at the 2022 san diego comic con with
powerful action and strikes of lightning
these glimpses of black adam offered
audiences some clues as to the tone and
direction of the feature most notably
the latest dceu film offers an
appropriately contrasting energy to the
2019 outing shazam with both titular
characters closely linked in the comic
book lore illuminating their differences
as natural enemies as a strategic
maneuver the lighthearted often immature
tone of shazam is in line with the theme
of a child turned superhero
good yeah good you're really on top of
this stuff meanwhile the trailers for
black adam decisively point out that its
headliner is 5000 years old and
correspondingly grumpy further
dissecting the trailer audiences can
expect a detailed backstory of how black
adam gained his powers mixed with the
struggles the character faces as an
immortal entity additionally the sneak
peaks include a new team of heroes for
the dc eu the justice society of america
included in the group's ranks is
character dr fate as well as the first
looks at hawkman cyclone and atom
smasher how this team interacts with the
leading character is certain to be a
driving factor of the entire film based
on the source material the inclusion of
sarah shahi as isis may imply a romantic
subplot that changes how black adam
behaves in this film and any other
future projects
dc has been planning the character's big
screen breakout for a very long time its
road to a theatrical release has been
very much of the long and winding sort
that's primarily a result of the dceu
re-evaluating the way they approached
their cinematic world in the wake of the
colossal misfire that was justice league
it also had to do with the dc wanting to
release shazam before introducing that
hero's arch enemy finally it was also a
late in the game executive decision to
the effect that black adam was a rich
enough character to support the solo
film of his own initially black adam was
scheduled to hit theaters on december 22
2021 as something of a nice holiday gift
for dc fans far and wide of course as
with many other entertainment projects
large and small the covet 19 pandemic
significantly delayed its filming
schedule landing it a new release date
of july 29 2022 then the film's megastar
himself announced in march that black
adam was pushed back amidst an overall
reshuffling by warner brothers of its
upcoming major films release dates
according to deadline currently black
adam is scheduled to premiere in
theaters on october 21 2022
obviously the one and only dwayne the
rock johnson will star in black adam mr
johnson has been quite vocal about
wanting to play the role since first
circling it back in 2014. dc's and
warner brothers haphazard attempts to
play ketchup in the universe building
approach likely hindered the development
of several other dc properties including
johnson's black atom now that the dcu
has found its footing via hits like
wonder woman aquaman and shazam johnson
will finally get to bring black adam to
comic loving audiences everywhere
johnson is so excited to get into
character that he's been teasing fans
via instagram about getting into
fighting shape from the movie ever since
his casting was announced and yes it
appears he'll be getting even more buff
than usual for the project despite the
fact that the two heroes are perennial
rivals it seems warner brothers has no
intention of bringing zachary levi's
billy batson shazam into the mix just
yet and levi himself has said that the
two foes likely won't square off until
shazam 3. joining johnson is a cast that
includes a mix of well-known names and
newcomers alike as of the film's most
recent casting announcement by a
deadline black adam will feature noah
centeno as the heroic atom smasher
pierce brosnan will play justice society
of america member dr fate aldous hodge
is team leader hawkman quintessa
swindell is tornado-based hero cyclone
sarasashi plays a significant comic book
character named adriana tomas marwan
kinsari bodhisombanji muhammad amar
james kassadi moyer and young rock lead
yuli ledekafu will all appear in
capacities that have yet to be disclosed
i'm ready
start right now if you want to
while we have some idea of who will be
appearing in the black adam movie
alongside mr rock we currently know next
to nothing about the film's plot dc and
warner brothers are remaining fiercely
tight-lipped about this aspect of the
project however despite the fact that we
don't quite know exactly what team dc
has in store for the blackout movie
there are still some things we can glean
ahead of any official story
announcements first and foremost it's
worth noting that black adam will indeed
be the character's first appearance in
the dc eu as such it's a safe bet that
black adam will serve as an origin story
of sorts that said johnson shared the
film's opening scene during the 2021 dc
fandom event and in that footage black
adam is already an established
superhuman within the film's fictional
world so while the movie may simply
begin chronologically with black adam's
re-awakening as suggested by this clip
it's also possible that it might jump
back in time after its opening scene to
establish the character's conception for
screen rant johnson himself has said
he'll be playing up the anti-hero side
of black adam's story rather than his
villainous tendencies over the course of
the film he may even be pushing the
character into more straight-up hero
territory which should make for an
interesting showdown when he eventually
meets up with shazam or dare we say even
superman on the big screen
holy moly
what would the dark knight be without
christopher nolan or would wonder woman
have packed the same punch without patty
jenkins it is becoming more and more
relevant to have a great director behind
a super powered blockbuster thankfully
black adam found its director in
spanish-born joe macletsera best known
for horror films such as orphan or the
paris hilton-led house of wax the
director previously worked with dwayne
johnson on the 2021 disney feature
jungle cruise in an interview with
deadline colette sarah explained how he
ended up on the dc comics project i
gravitated toward the origin story of
this unconventional character the season
director further detailed the morality
of the subject and plot describing black
adam as the quote dirty harry of
superheroes that understanding of the
story clearly resonated with the star as
the rock also confirmed at cinemacon
that the 1971 clint eastwood feature was
the inspiration and quote north star for
the direction of black adam
black adam is a project that has been in
the works for an extremely long time at
least compared to other comic book
adaptations as far back as 2014 the rock
confirmed via twitter that he would be
taking the role of the anti-hero black
adam that same year dc said its
intentions of repeating marvel's success
by manufacturing its own cinematic
universe and despite dwayne johnson
being tied to the franchise the
character unexpectedly failed to appear
in any of the previous outings including
shazam where a cameo would have made
logical sense
the exception of course is his recent
black atom cameo and an animated dc film
released in 2022 dc league of super pets
features a collection of superhero
animal friends facing their own
adventure coincidentally the rock stars
in the film as superman's lovable canine
crypto and as the film premiered the
former wrestler was quick to reveal an
after credit scene featuring none other
than black adam and his own pet dog
regardless of dc's roller coaster of
success at the box office the rock has
remained an advocate for the black adam
movie the footballer turned wrestler
turned actor has been wide open about
what draws him to the character which he
surprisingly refers to as a superhero
despite black adam historically being
written as the villain
with johnson's monumental success as a
movie star the actor likely had his
choice of comic book heroes to portray
after 2008's iron man initiated the rise
of annotations however he has chosen to
champion black adam into existence he is
the films and characters most prominent
advocate going as far as to say that his
character has the upper hand over
superman the truth is
i was born to play black adam
considering the ever growing list of
cancelled dceu movies the fact that
black adam is so close to release is a
near miracle as criticism over the
warner backed films has been
inconsistent the powers that be have
dropped the proverbial acts on multiple
planned projects this includes a cyborg
solo feature a justice league sequel and
a slew of other unrealized movies at
various points in pre-production
most recently batgirl had concluded
filming and was all but set for release
before studio heads trashed the feature
yet black adam with a dark cape flapping
past has narrowly skimmed through the
multiple termination sprees the
tumultuous road to publication didn't
stop once the camera started rolling
either black adam faced further
obstacles during production that ranged
from coping with a global pandemic to
overcoming troublesome scores from test
screenings through some test scores had
black adam rated equal to the now
cancelled batgirl movie the rock led
feature was forced into reshoots with
the studio unwilling to scrap the
reportedly 185 million project
before diving further into speculation
and character analysis there are some
nuts and bolts about the film worth
covering officially the movie has not
announced the run time however a
parent's guide from filmyrating has the
movie clocked at an hour and 48 minutes
based on previous dceu films the 108
minute watch seems a little short with
shazam clocking in at 132 minutes and
the longest movie in the franchise zack
snyder's justice league lands at an
astonishing 242 minutes yet 2020's
harley quinn birds of prey finished at
109 minutes making a shorter black adam
film a real possibility
equally black adam has not yet received
an official rating from the motion
picture association of america however
there is much less need for speculation
according to dwayne johnson's production
company seven bucks black adam was
filmed intentionally aiming for a pg-13
rating despite the rise of r-rated comic
book films the story of the anti-hero
did not call for the additional
profanities seen in movies like the
suicide squad but there is reason to
believe that black adam will lean
towards the harder end of the pg-13
rating as the intense violence and
visuals showcased in the trailers
suggest a darker dceu movie
although he often crosses paths with
shazam's captain marvel and shares the
same lightning bolt across his chest
black adam's powers differ from his red
suited nemesis most prominently captain
marvel the dc version gains his powers
by calling out an acronym of six greek
gods while black adam who also yells
shazam is bestowed his abilities by
egyptian gods the stamina of shu offers
black adam endurance and sustenance
meaning he can live without food water
or air the god horus gives him
superhuman speed in flight strength
equal to that of superman comes from
aemon meanwhile the wisdom of zahuti and
the power of aten make black adam not
only super intelligent but able to use
magic an ability that often gives him
the upper hand and finally the courage
of mehan makes him invulnerable needless
to say black adam is a powerhouse of
super abilities equal to and often
surpassing the strongest we have seen
like superman and captain marvel however
the character is not without his limits
most interestingly yet inconsistently
explored in the comics the 5 000 year
old adam is stuck in his powerful form
unlike the hero of shazam black adam
can't transform back and forth between
superhero and child by saying one word
if he were to revert to his original
self his body would disintegrate aging
the thousands of years at a past
as a character black adam has been
around since 1945 when fawcett comics
still published captain marvel and the
rest of the shazam family long before
their rights were sold to dc his true
name is teth adam and he was bestowed
powers by the same wizard that appears
in the shazam movie however instead of
using his powerful abilities to protect
the world adam decided that he should be
its ruler and assumed the throne of
egypt betrayed the wizard banished the
aran champion to the most distant star
in the universe taking thousands of
years to return to earth black adam
arrives to find a new champion is taking
his place surprisingly the shazam
villain appeared only once under the
original publisher it was not until dc
owned the rights that black adam would
return in 1975. since then the character
has been prominently utilized as a
villain to dc's most powerful heroes
including captain marvel superman and
the justice league at times black adam
is reformed to become a hero but he is
often portrayed as an anti-hero
defending his own beliefs of what is
good and protecting his home of kondok
a significant inclusion in the upcoming
black adam movie is the cinematic
introduction of the justice society of
america as much as this collective of
superhero seems like a derivative of
justice league the jsa predates the
latter by two decades the original
concept behind the golden age team was
to combine characters from two sister
companies into one series all-star
comics
the blended stories included members
from both dc comics and all-american
comics until 1946 when the characters
were amalgamated under one publisher
title
dc comics later rectified the
inconsistent storylines in the 1985
limited series crisis on infinite earths
canonically making the jsa a defunct
world war ii era super team the earliest
members of the jsa included characters
that have now become extremely popular
including green lantern and flash
however much of the initial lineup
remains intact for the upcoming black
adam film specifically doctor fate and
hawkman while adam smasher is a
descendant of the original atom
throughout the years there have been new
iterations of the jsa introducing new
members along the way meanwhile the team
has appeared on multiple dc television
shows including smallville legends of
tomorrow and star girl and depending on
the reception of black adam warner
brothers is receptive to the idea of
creating a spin-off movie for the unique
team of heroes
make this one count
the dc eu timeline is loose potentially
broken and not nearly as streamlined as
the marvel cinematic universe the pair
of wonder woman movies fill points in a
timeline that seemingly centers around
the 2017 justice league feature however
the inconsistent doubleheader of 2016
suicide squad and james gunns the
suicide squad mixed with differently
aged actors portraying batman convolute
to cinematic universe a universe that is
about to get even messier with an
upcoming the flash movie that reportedly
involves significant time travel the
whole order of things is difficult
enough to keep sorted out without
including another time spanning
character so where does black adam fit
into the dceu timeline that is otherwise
fractured as seen in the release
trailers the story begins thousands of
years ago making it simple to choose an
awakening point to align with certain
characters and events
with the news that viola davis amanda
waller character from the suicide squad
is set to appear in black adam the story
will likely take place in the modern day
after the events of justice league the
choice to bring black adam into the dceu
as it currently stands would simplify
any future pronouns with established
characters such as superman and shazam
however an explanation will be necessary
for why the justice society of america
is reacting to the film's events instead
of characters that previously existed in
the universe
as a wrestler one of dwayne johnson's
most famous lines goes can you smell
what the rock is cooking the phrase
holds some depth nowadays as the a-list
movie star is intentionally stirring the
dceu pot johnson is putting much stock
in his new super-powered character to
pave the way for a revived dc cinematic
collection during his arrival at the
2022 san diego comic-con event a large
screen behind him boldly stated the dc
universe will never be the same during
the hall h trailer premiere the rock
doubled down on the statement saying the
idea behind the film was how can we
create something that's fresh unique
maybe show and create things that have
never been done maybe we can issue a new
era in the dc universe maybe it's time
for a shift get in there and disrupt a
little bit and listen to the fans
given the unstoppable popularity of
superhero films and the universal
approval of dwayne johnson's electric
charm it seems natural for dc to want to
sign the former wrestler up for a
trilogy of movies truthfully they hit
the lottery when the big name star found
a character he resonated with so deeply
within their roster instead of the
competitors
unfortunately dc projects are on shaky
ground at warner brothers studio so the
future of dwayne johnson's character in
the dc eu highly depends on the
reception of his inaugural outing
producer for johnson's seven bucks
productions company hiram garcia spoke
about the potential follow-up with
collider saying
we have big plans obviously for the dc
universe if the fans perceive the way we
want
you